Before we show you, a computationally more feasible way
of proving theorems in logic, or proving the truth value of sentence in logic.
We should point out that so far, we have been using only propositional logic.
Propositional logic is sometimes also called the zero-if order logic.
The key aspect of propulsion logic, is that it does not have any variables. So
as an example, I may have a sentence that says if the animal Lays-eggs,
and the animal Flies, then the animal is a Bird.
And here I'm talking about a specific animal. Well, sometimes I might want to
talk about, animals in general, any animal, all animals. In that case,
I would want to introduce a variables in it. So in first audilogic,
otherwise known as predicate calculus, I might want to say something like.
If x Lays-eggs and x Flies, then x is a Bird.
Which has a set form very similar to form here, except that instead of animal,
I now have a variable. Now, I have a variable here. But, I must also
specify the range of the variable. And what I really want to say here is for
all animals. Therefore I'll introduce a new quantifier over the variable x.
This quantifier is called Universal Quantifier. It is denoted with the symbol,
this is the symbol for Universal Quantifier. And this says now for all x,
if x Lays-eggs, and x Flies it implies that x is a Bird.
One thing to note here is that, I could have rewritten this sentence,
with the Universal Quantifier back into proposition logic. But,
having lots of sentences like this. In proposition logic. So I could've said
Lays-eggs (animal) one, Flies (animal) one implies Bird (animal) one,
Lays-eggs (animal) two, and Flies (animal) two implies Bird (animal) two.
And so on and so forth, for each and every animal that is possible.
But, by writing it in the form of a variable, a Universal Quantifier statement,
I can reduce the number of sentences I have to write into just one sentence. So
we have introduced variables, and we have talked at least about
one quantifier so far, the Universal Quantifier, that applies for
all values that that variable can take. Sometimes I might want to specify
a different range of the variable. Not all values of the variable can take, but,
at least some values of the variable I can take. So consider again,
this sentence, here the animal is [UNKNOWN] a specific animal. Now let's look at
the second sentence on this screen. And this sentence is the variable y.
It says if y Lays-eggs and y Flies then it implies that y is a Bird.
This sentence is a very similar form, to the previous except for
the variable y. I can specify the value, that the variable y can take.
This time I want to specify not that this sentence is true for all values of y,
for all animals, but simply that it is true for. Some at least one animal
in which case I'll use an Existential Quantifier. Here is the symbol for
an Existential Quantifier, this Existential Quantifier says that there is at
least one animal, for which this sentence happens to be true.